thank you thank you all for being here
today okay so my thesis proposal is on
genomic instability of solid tumors and
clinical applications so genomic
instability is a hallmark of all cancer
types so basically this includes high
frequency of mutations and chromosomal
instability and so basically what this
figure is showing is chromosomes that
are located in the nucleus of a cell and
then each section is a gene and then
below that is a human karyotype which is
the original way that chromosomes were
viewed under a microscope and you can
see that each chromosome has kind of a
different shape and structure and so the
this basically exists on a scale of
genomic variation so clinical
cytogenetics includes discussions about
gene fusions and chromosomal instability
on a much larger scale and so you can
see that on the right side of this scale
this can include whole chromosomes or
parts of chromosomes that are duplicated
or deleted whereas
genomic instability also includes point
mutations on a smaller scale which is on
which is on the left side of this scale
and so this is basically like a one
nucleotide change whereas chromosome
abnormality is on a larger scale so
researchers have used information from
different scales to summarize
instability in solid tumors and the
clinical utility is uncertain whereas
chromosomal abnormalities such as these
structural changes or gene fusions are
routinely used for clinical decision
making so when we talk about clinical
decision making this really depends on
the cancer type and this can include
different types of genetic variation
which is useful for clinical decision
making so one of the most known examples
is the Philadelphia chromosome in CML
and so basically what this is is a
reciprocal translocation from chromosome
9 to
zone 22 and what what this does is it
creates a fusion gene known as BCR Abel
one and this causes uncontrollable so
growth in CML and this is used for
clinical diagnosis predicting survival
and treatment options and so basically a
side of man tells you where on the
chromosome you are so in this case we
have Q thirty four point one so
basically the side of band is 9q
thirty-four point one another example is
in ammo which also uses cytogenetics for
clinical decision-making and so the
example for that is p ml rara which is
also a fusion gene and this is a
translocation from chromosome 15 to 17
and this is used for a diagnosis of
subtypes of AML and also for treatment
plans but when we think of like breast
cancer and ovarian cancer it's mostly
subtyping based on mutations and so
that's more on the smaller scale that i
was talking about and so an example of
this is like Bracco 1 a 2 mutation which
is used for diagnosis and treatment
plants so there are different types of
chromosomal abnormality structures this
includes deletion duplication inversion
substitution and translocation as we saw
in the previous example and so there are
basically lots of different ways to
measure this chromosomal abnormality
structure and there's currently no good
way to summarize this so in hematologic
malignancies versus solid tumors
basically recurrent findings have been
consistently associated with clinical
measures and leukemias and the samples
are found in the bone marrow and the
chromosomal instability measures are
found in almost all the leukemia cells
whereas in solid tumors the findings are
not as consistent compared to leukemias
and basically the quality of the
chromosomes are suboptimal because of
the cancer cells before culturing and
there's also complex chromosomal changes
due to the tumor progression
and so it's difficult to identify
primary chromosomal changes for each
tumor type however there are new
techniques and better characterization
of solid tumors which is made from a
zonal instability a promising marker for
solid tumors so again despite these
challenges chromosomal abnormality has
had clinical advances in research such
as in breast cancer they found that the
fish assay in combination with her 2 and
chromosome 17 sequences this was more
accurate and then protein expression
alone in selecting patients that would
respond to targeted therapy and in head
and neck cancer the fish assay was also
used to monitor on surgical margins by
identifying chromosomal imbalances in
the head and neck tumor samples
so basically chromosomal instability
scores were developed to measure
different kinds of instabilities because
these methods are not routinely used in
clinical decision making for solid
tumors so I'll be talking about three
different chromosomal instability scores
and so this incorporates gene expression
copy number and somatic mutation so the
first one I'm going to talk about is the
CIN 25 which is basically a 25 gene
signature across patient samples and
this is used as a classifier for
prognosis and so basically these 25
genes were selected based on the
correlation with functional aneuploidy
and this is calculated as a T statistic
across diverse tumor types and so on the
left you can see the heat map which is
basically each row is the gene from the
25 gene signature and each column is the
patient and the net CIN signature is
basically
the net score for each patient and then
the middle line is the average and so
they classify each patient into low and
high categories based on the average and
so as you can see from the survival plot
the patients with the lower cin score
actually survive more than the ones with
the higher score and so basically what
this survival curve is is a kaplan-meier
survival curve with a p-value at the
0.05 level and this calculates the
fraction of patients known to have
survived across time and the p-value
corresponds to a log rank test comparing
the pair of survival curves and so you
can see that the patients that had that
were classified with a lower cin score
they actually survived a higher fraction
of the patients survived than the
patients with a higher cin score and so
this di n25 performed well for 12 out of
the 18 data sets that they tested and in
this particular example this is the
breast cancer data set so I'll move on
to the next score which is based on both
copy number and somatic mutation and
this is basically a weighted calculation
of the copy number and the somatic
mutations and so what they found is that
a higher GI scores associated with the
higher survival rate in ovarian cancer
and this is regardless of Braca 1 & 2
mutations and so basically they adjusted
for the bracket 1 & 2 mutations by
computing survival for high and low GI
scores with each group containing the
bracket one of two mutations versus
Bracco wild-type and so they found that
the higher group had a higher survival
rate meaning that this score can be used
to further divide Braca mutant ovarian
tumors and so this is kind of the
opposite finding that they had for the
cin score where a higher cin score was
associated with a lower survival rate
so then the last square I'm going to
talk about is the C index which is a
package on bioconductor and this is
based solely on copy number and so they
calculated this score for each
chromosome and for each sample and so
they calculated this at the chromosome
level and then also at the site Oban
level which is on a smaller scale and
they found that a higher loss cin score
was associated with better prognosis and
almost the entire chromosome 20
chromosome 20 was lost in the relapse
free group so this is a little bit
different group because this is
comparing patients that are relapse
verses relapse free whereas the previous
ones were based solely on survival so
this is the summary of the scores that I
talked about and so the cin 25 basically
performed well for 12 out of the 18 data
sets and they used the gene expression
data only and their finding was that a
higher cin score was associated with the
worst prognosis and this was tested in
multiple cancer types and then the GI
score was tested for one tumor type and
they use both copy number and somatic
mutation and a higher score was
associated with better prognosis in the
ovarian cancer data set and then the c
index score was also performed well in
one tumor type and they used only copy
number and a higher law score meaning
that a higher deletion score of the
chromosome was associated with a better
prognosis for a colorectal cancer so
basically there's a gap in the research
where associations with clinical
outcomes have been inconsistent and
there's no consensus about the best way
to summarize these scores and recurrence
cytogenetic abnormalities like we see in
al are not included in the scores for
solid tumors so there's a potential
clinical value of cin as a predictor of
cancer progression so the hypothesis is
that using combinations of these current
chromosomal instability measures which
utilizes different data types this will
provide a greater ability to predict
outcomes across a wide variety of
cancers and so the motivation for this
is that this will provide researchers a
way to annotate the cancer samples with
these different measures of genomic
instability and to be able to provide
evidence for which measures are most
predictive of clinical features in a
variety of solid tumors so this brings
me to aim one which is basically to
develop an AR software package to be
launched through a bio conductor and
this will provide comprehensive
annotations related to genomic
instability for TCGA samples and this
will include coding in our Linux and
Python so this is just an overview of
the number of samples in TCGA and this
is just to show that there is coverage
for all of the data types available in
TCGA for these cancer types and there is
some variability among the samples but
we do have coverage for the clinical
data copy number somatic mutation and a
gene expression so I'll be studying
these four cancer types because the
first three are for validation and the
last one for kidney cancer that's I'm a
new dataset that hasn't been implemented
with the CIN scores and so basically
I'll be downloading the the TCGA data
from the GDC data portal and this will
include gene expression copy number and
somatic mutation and the levels just
indicate that this is open source data
and so it's not controlled access and
that means that the somatic mutations
don't contain any germline mutations and
then I'll also be downloading the
recurrent chromosome aberrations in the
middlemen database which is basically
more of the structural changes and so
you can see an example of that on the
bottom table here
so basically when I'm processing the cin
score I'll be annotating this for all
the TCGA patients so the cin 25 is the
gene expression GI is the somatic
mutation plus copy number and then the C
index is the copy number at the
chromosome and the site Oban level and
then I'll also identify the high
frequent the high frequency chromosomal
abnormalities and so an example of what
this looks like in the middlemen
database is the structural variation
will basically be the side AB and so in
the first row its
1q 10 so chromosome 10 on the bigger arm
at location 10 and in this example it's
in insertion or also substitution and so
basically what happens this part of the
chromosome gets inserted into a
different chromosome and this occurs in
18 percent of the breast cancer cases in
the middleman database and a 25 percent
in ovarian cancer and then the next two
examples are derivative and addition
which is basically duplication and a
derivative is similar to the other
measures that I talked about which is
like a combination of inversion and
deletion so in this case it's a deletion
of chromosome 16 and inverted on to
chromosome 1 so the validation will
basically be seeking to validate what
the previous studies found and so this
will involve checking the cin 25 score
and seeing if a higher score denotes a
worse prognosis and breast cancer and
therefore the GI score if a higher score
is a better prognosis in ovarian cancer
and for the C index if a higher law
score is a better prognosis in
colorectal cancer so this will be
validation of the scores using different
data sets but it will be the same tumor
types
and so the last thing in aim one will
basically be the exploratory data
analysis of the scores and so all
quarterly at the different scores to see
if they're providing any new information
and if they are highly correlated and
this will affect the regression analysis
with possible on multicollinearity and
I'll check if there's any statistical
differences in the proportions and the
clinical variables such as the age tumor
stages and primary versus metastatic
tumors and then also be checking the
differences in the score distributions
across the tumor types and so this is
for the EDA so then for aim - I'll
actually be investigating the predictive
ability of genomic instability
annotations across these variety of
cancer types and this is just an example
of like what the CIN 25 score like what
the visualization will look like for
that and so it's that same idea with the
heat map and then the loan high scores
and then what the survival curve looks
like for those so some of the analysis
questions are is there a zi n
combination score that better predict
survival in diverse cancer types and
basically I'll be doing a multiple
survival analysis for this and also
investigate whether a combination of CIN
scores better predict survival in any
one score alone and also is there a
significant difference in the CIN scores
of TCGA patients in different tumor
stages or primary versus metastatic
tumors and so to answer this question
I'll do a logistic regression to
determine if CIN scores are
significantly different between these
groups and then similarly I'll be
investigating whether a combination of
CIN scores better predict survival than
any one score alone and then the last
question I'll be looking at is to create
a region specific instability score and
so this will be this will be looking at
whether the important side of man scores
are those known that have recurrent
abnormalities and so I'll determine if
there's chromosomes specific or side up
and specific scores that are more
predictive than instability scores based
on the entire genome and so this is my
timeline for my thesis so this summer it
will mostly be working on our album
mostly working on research data
collection and then the software
engineering of the our bioconductor
package so this will involve downloading
and parsing the data across the four
cancer types that I mentioned and then
also downloading parsing the middleman
database and then annotate annotating
the cin scores and then validation and
then wrapping that up into an r package
and then fall term I'll be working on
more of the data analysis with the
scores and then also the data
visualization piece which will probably
be through SHINee and then also be
looking at the best way to summarize CIN
scores and which ones predict better and
so as I mentioned before the
deliverables will be in our BIOS notre
package and so this will basically
function to process data from any cancer
type from TCGA and supports a variety of
data types so math files text files CSV
or Excel sheets and then basically this
will output the clean data with the CIN
annotations and then I'll also do a
separate piece which is the data
visualization tool which will show the
results including heat map survival
curves for each the ion score and how
they how they perform across each of the
cancer types and then I'll make
recommendations about the most
appropriate way to summarize genomic
instability and
and the summary of which data types are
useful for each cancer type so the
innovation of this project is that it
will provide evidence for which measures
of genomic instability are most
predictive in a variety of tumor types
and tumor stage hasn't been implemented
as a clinical outcome in the previous
methods that I described and then also
be investigating the utility of
incorporating information about the
known recurrent chromosome abnormalities
so the next steps of this research might
involve the beginning of more clinically
based research based on the how the
science scores do for each tumor type so
the limitations of this study include
variability among follow tumor samples
between the previous studies and the
TCGA which may affect the validation
step of the previous studies and there's
also variability of data coverage for
each data type for each tumor type which
will affect the score annotations so for
example some patients may have a GI
score but not a CIN score because
they're missing gene expression and also
the sample size differences across tumor
types will affect the distributions of
the score and so basically the breast
cancer data set will have a more narrow
distribution of scores versus yeah there
are data type the other tumor types
because it has almost twice the amount
of samples and then these are my
references and then I would just like to
thank my thesis advisory committee and
demise faculty and staff and students
and my friends and family so I'll take
questions
what um based on the evidence maybe it
would give them something to think about
you know especially with like breast
cancer and ovarian cancer you typically
think about the mutations but maybe if
you add an expression that might
convince them like this actually predict
survival better or worse and it might
actually show you it might you might be
able to subtype that based on the tumor
stage and so that might be able to give
them an idea of like how they might
stratify treatment and so it would just
basically start that conversation
[Laughter]
yeah that was one of my questions - I
was like well what if I don't validate
the original scores and that's just
something I'll have to think about so
maybe combining the scores would
validate the previous studies which
would be really interesting or terms of
validation yeah it's almost like it's
almost like proving that there is so
much variability in the tumor types and
that it really depends on the tumor and
that maybe there is some other way to
score these
okay yeah that's a good point yeah
okay I do think that's interesting from
the patient perspective too because
typically at least for breast cancer
it's all about the bracket 1 & 2
mutations so if you were able to
incorporate expression and copy number
that might help them understand it more
- OH
all right yeah all right yeah they're
all they're all primary tumor samples
before treatment all right thank you
you